la gare internationale de delle dans le
territoire de belfort vient d'être
inaugurée officiellement une cérémonie
chasse l'autre un demi-siècle après ces
images france et suisse s'apprête à
inaugurer leur nouveau trait d'union une
liaison internationale belfort-delle
version 2.0 c'est en 2015 après 23 ans
de jachère que la sncf ouvre le dossier
dépose le premier rail d'une ligne que
l'on pensait définitivement enterré leur
est solennel on dépose l'ensemble des
voies existantes
et puis derrière on repose une nouvelle
infrastructure électrifié pour un coût
global de 110 millions d'euros
c'est quand même un chantier d'envergure
un très très gros chantier c'est le plus
grand actuellement sur le territoire de
la bourgogne franche comté c'est
structurant pour nos territoires d'abord
il s'agisse du département du territoire
de belfort où la franche-comté
généralement du canton du jura mais d
autres cantons suisses du nord-ouest
ainsi que dans la relations
internationales à destination du tgv les
cheminots avaient donc raison lorsqu en
1992 il refuse l douloureuse a dû aux
trains de proximité
les manifestations organisées à l'époque
n'y avait pourtant rien fait chiffres en
main la direction de la sncf comptait
une ligne déficitaire
deux trains quotidiens pour une
vingtaine de passagers seulement il faut
dire que leurs horaires ne connaît pas
franchement aux habitudes des
frontaliers un millier de voyageurs 100
fois plus nombreux nous nous écartons un
peu de notre véritable rôle de service
public au service de la population
privée de voyageurs puis de fret et
enfin de son dernier guichet la guerre
internationale de dell ferment 95 pour
ouvrir dans quelques heures
ces allers-retours mettront dès la 25
minute de belfort et permettront aux
suisses d'accéder roux tgv le service
public est de retour sur les rails pour
un autre demi siècle
l'avenir nous le dira